This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you drive from Oakland to Los Angeles in February, you'll pass through a spectacular scene. Neat, symmetrical rows of trees covered with pink and white flowers, stretching on for hundreds of miles. This is the annual California Almond Plume, and it really is massive. is the annual California almond bloom, and it really is massive. California almond trees take up a million acres of land in the Central Valley. When the petals fall off, they carpet the road and create this sweet smell. And the almond bloom also has its own distinctive sound. You can actually hear it before you even walk into the orchard.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你在二月份从奥克兰开车去洛杉矶，你会路过一番壮观的景象。整齐、对称的树木排列着，开满了粉色和白色的花朵，绵延数百英里。这就是一年一度的加州杏树花海，而且它真的很宏大。这就是一年一度的加州杏树花海，而且它真的很宏大。加州杏树在中央谷地占据了一百万英亩的土地。当花瓣落下时，它们铺满道路，散发出这种甜美的气味。而且杏树花开也有其独特的声音。甚至在你走进果园之前，你就能听到它。
That's the sound of thousands of bees from an orchard outside of Modesto, California. To create a single almond, a blossom needs as many as it does in bee visits. That means you need roughly 80,000 bees to pollinate an acre of almonds. That's Adam Ellington, he's a reporter covering the environment for Bloomberg. He also hosts the podcast, The Business of Bees. When you think of bees in business, you're probably thinking of honey. But in fact, honey has little to do with commercial beekeeping today. Every winter, beekeepers from every corner of the United States descend on California to pollinate almonds. Almonds have a window
那是加州莫德斯托郊外一个果园里成千上万只蜜蜂的声音。为了产生一颗杏子，一朵花需要经历与蜜蜂造访次数相当多的接触。这意味着你需要大约8万只蜜蜂来为一英亩的杏树授粉。那是亚当·埃灵顿，他是彭博社的一名环境报道记者。他还主持播客节目《蜜蜂的生意》。当你想到商业中的蜜蜂时，你可能首先会想到蜂蜜。但事实上，今天的商业养蜂与蜂蜜几乎没有什么关系。每年冬天，来自美国各个角落的养蜂人都会蜂拥至加州为杏树授粉。杏树有一个窗口期
of about two weeks for pollination to occur. Otherwise, the blossoms won't turn into fruit. The demand is so high, it takes almost every bee hive in the country to do the job. Upwards of two million hives. This is the largest managed pollination event on Earth. This is John Miller. He's a fourth generation beekeeper from North Dakota. In every year, John brings 13,000 hives over 1,500 miles
大约两周的授粉时间。否则，花朵就不会变成果实。这种需求太高了，几乎需要全国所有的蜂箱来完成这项工作。多达两00万个蜂箱。这是地球上最大规模的人工授粉活动。这是约翰·米勒。他是来自北达科他州的第四代养蜂人。每年，约翰都会带着13000个蜂箱跨越1500多英里
to the Central Valley. I've got the best job on earth. Look at this. It's a beautiful spring day in Northern California. All my trees are in bloom. I just love it. So what are we looking at right here? This is the top of the hive. These are the occupants. These are the little bees. They're hanging out. There's a...there's... This guy just landed. For a beekeeper like John, pollination isn't just big business.
来到中央谷地。我有世上最好的工作。你看这个。这是北加州一个美丽的春日。我所有的树都在开花。我太喜欢了。那么我们现在看到的是什么？这是蜂箱的顶部。这些是里面的住客。这些是小蜜蜂。它们在闲逛。有个……有个……这家伙刚刚降落。对于像约翰这样的养蜂人来说，授粉不仅仅是一桩大生意。
It's most of his business. In recent years, almond pollination has become so lucrative it accounts for about two-thirds of John's income. How much of this honey actually will go to making honey for people to eat? None. Instead of selling the honey, John says it's more cost-effective to just leave it in the hive as food for the bees. After pollinating almonds, John will load his bees onto a semi-truck and they'll move from one crop to another in other states.
这是他大部分的业务。近年来，杏树授粉变得非常 lucrative（利润丰厚），占了约翰收入的大约三分之二。这些蜂蜜实际上有多少会用来做人类食用的蜂蜜呢？没有。约翰说，与其出售蜂蜜，不如把它留在蜂箱里作为蜜蜂的食物更划算。在给杏树授粉后，约翰会把蜜蜂装上半挂卡车，它们将前往其他州的另一个农作物产地。
You know, they'll go from almonds to plums to cherries to apples to vine crops to pit fruits to cotton to lime of beans to watermelons and then their season is over. Farmers have known for centuries that putting a hive of honey bees in an orchard results in more blossoms becoming cherries, almonds, or apples. But it's only in the last 30 years that pollination services like the kind that John provides have become such an enormous part of American agriculture. Today bees have become more livestock than wild creatures, basically tiny little winged cows that depend on humans for
你知道的，它们会从杏子到李子、樱桃、苹果、藤本作物、核果、棉花、利马豆、西红柿，然后它们的季节就结束了。几个世纪以来，农民们一直都知道，在果园里放一个蜜蜂箱会使更多的花朵变成樱桃、杏子或苹果。但直到过去30年，像约翰所提供的这种授粉服务才成为美国农业中如此巨大的一部分。今天，蜜蜂已经变得更像是家畜而不是野生动物，基本上是长着翅膀的微型奶牛，依靠人类提供
shelter, food, and even medicine. But for thousands of years our relationship with bees was much simpler. It was really all about the honey. Way before sugar came along, honey was one of the few sweeteners we had. There are 8,000-year-old cave paintings in Spain of people collecting wild honey, and once humans got a taste for honey, they do almost anything to get it. Alexander Zamcheck is an apoculturist at the University of Miami, Ohio. He studies bees and agriculture. To put it gently, we
庇护所、食物甚至药物。但在几千年来，我们与蜜蜂的关系要简单得多。这其实全是为了蜂蜜。早在糖出现之前，蜂蜜是我们拥有的为数不多的甜味剂之一。西班牙有8000年历史的岩画，上面画着人们收集野蜂蜜的情景，一旦人类尝到了蜂蜜的甜头，他们就会不择手段地得到它。亚历山大·扎姆切克是俄亥俄州迈阿密大学的一位养蜂学家。他研究蜜蜂和农业。委婉地说，我们
found ourselves as plunders. When we tripped across natural beehives, the Winnie the Pooh trees and the wild. And when people came across one of these trees, they would cut it down. And in so doing, rob the bees of this honey, it was not a wonderful experience. We didn't have bee suits. It was a pretty raw event. These collectors would smother and kill the bees with smoke, and then they'd take the honey. It was not exactly a sustainable process. Slowly over time, it really dawned on us that, well, what if we tried to put them in a container? By the middle ages, beekeepers in Europe had
发现自己就像掠夺者。当我们偶然发现天然蜂巢——也就是小熊维尼树和野外时。当人们偶然发现其中一棵树时，他们就会把它砍倒。这样做就掠夺了蜜蜂的蜂蜜，这可不是什么美妙的经历。我们没有防蜂服。这是一个相当原始的事件。这些采集者会用烟把蜜蜂熏死，然后拿走蜂蜜。这绝对不是一个可持续的过程。慢慢地，随着时间的推移，我们终于意识到，好吧，如果我们试着把它们放进容器里会怎么样？到了中世纪，欧洲的养蜂人已经
designed a method of capturing swarms of bees and then putting them inside woven upside-down baskets called skeps. For all you vuxilologists out there, there's actually a bee-skep on the state flag of Utah. It's got a little door for the bees to come in and out and it's positioned right in the center between the words Utah and industry. An obvious advantage of the skep design was that you didn't have to go out and hunt for the honey and chop down a tree to get it. And the skeps were portable. When the first Europeans came to America, they brought along a few skeps full of honeyes, which are actually not native to North America. The species the Europeans brought over is called apes-molifra, it's Latin for honey carrier.
设计了一种方法，捕捉蜂群并将它们放进名为“skep”的编织倒扣篮子里。对于所有你们这些词源学家来说，犹他州的州旗上其实就有一个蜂箱（skep）。它有一个供蜜蜂进出的小门，位置正好在“Utah”和“industry”这两个词的正中央。蜂箱设计的一个显式优势是，你不用再出去寻找蜂蜜并砍倒一棵树来获取它了。而且这些蜂箱是便携的。当第一批欧洲人来到美洲时，他们随身带了几个装满蜜蜂的蜂箱，蜜蜂其实并非北美本土物种。欧洲人带来的物种叫做欧蜂（apis-mellifera），在拉丁语中是“运蜜者”的意思。
Of the 20,000 bee species in the world, apes-molifra is the only one that can produce enough honey to be useful for humans. It formed larger colonies, it had a gentle nature. It was a good honey producer, it was one that we could use around the world, and that was our golden retriever. In these dye-siles, sweet tempered bees did really well in America. There's a good saying by a 17th century scholar that said the honey bees did better than the settlers did.
在全世界的2万种蜜蜂中，欧蜂是唯一能够产出足够多蜂蜜以供人类使用的蜜蜂。它形成了更大的群体，性格温顺。它是一个很好的产蜜者，是我们可以在世界各地使用的品种，那是我们的金毛寻回犬。在这些环境中，脾气温和的蜜蜂在美洲表现得非常好。17世纪有一位学者说过一句很好的名言：“蜜蜂比定居者过得更好。”
That's Tammy Horne Potter. I am the Kentucky State APA artist. I work with the Kentucky Department of Agriculture. Tammy also wrote a book titled Bees in America, how the honeybees shaped a nation. And she says the honeybees loved their new continent. There were plenty of stands of a type of a species of tree called black gum. And black gum trees are notable because they decay from the inside out very quickly. They would swarm and take up residence in these trees.
那是塔米·霍恩·波特。我是肯塔基州立养蜂人。我和肯塔基州农业部合作。塔米还写了一本名为《美洲的蜜蜂：蜜蜂如何塑造一个国家》的书。她说，蜜蜂非常喜欢它们的新大陆。那里有大量被称为黑树胶的树木。黑树胶树引人注目，因为它们从内向外腐烂得非常快。它们会成群结队地在这个树里安家。
And so honeybees did very well. So by the middle of the 19th century, honeybees were well-established in North America. People were still keeping them in skepts or hunting small amounts of wild honey in nature, but eventually everything changed with a Presbyterian minister named Lorenzo Langstroff. After attending seminary at Yale, Langstroff returned to his hometown of Philadelphia in 1848, and during this time Langstroth began to struggle with mental illness. In diaries from the time, his family referred to it as head troubles. Today is what we'd call seasonal effective disorder.
所以蜜蜂过得很好。因此，到了19世纪中叶，蜜蜂已经在北美牢固地建立起来了。人们仍然把它们养在蜂箱里，或者在自然界中寻找少量的野蜂蜜，但最终一切随着一位名叫洛伦佐·兰斯特劳斯的长老会牧师而改变了。在耶鲁大学神学院学习后，兰斯特劳斯于1848年回到了他的家乡费城，在此期间，兰斯特劳斯开始与精神疾病作斗争。当时他的日记中，他的家人称之为“头部麻烦”。今天我们会称之为季节性情绪失调。
Back then, a standard prescription you fight depression would be lodenum. That's an alcoholic solution containing morphine. But Langstroth's doctor wanted to try something more gentle. He told him to spend more time outdoors, which he did. He would take long walks on his own out in nature, and he developed an extreme fascination with wild honeybees. He literally just spent hours and days and weeks and months staring at these hollow B-trees until an idea finally clicked in his mind.
当时，治疗抑郁症的标准处方是鸦片酊。那是一种含有吗啡的酒精溶液。但兰斯特劳斯的医生想尝试一些更温和的方法。他让他多花点时间在户外，他也照做了。他会在大自然中独自进行长时间的散步，并对野生蜜蜂产生了极大的痴迷。他字面意义上只是花了几小时、几天、几周和几个月的时间盯着这些中空的蜂树，直到一个想法终于在他的脑海中点击亮起。
Langstroth noticed something about B-hives in the wild. There was this pattern, a kind of mathematical precision to the spacing between the honeycombs. And the moment came when he realized there is the same exact space, a carpenters number, 3-8ths of an inch, between every one of these combs, and they were measured again and again,
兰斯特劳斯注意到野外蜂巢的一些事情。有一种模式，即蜂窝之间间距的一种数学精确度。那一刻他意识到，在每一个蜂窝之间都存在着完全相同的空间，一个木匠的数字——3/8英寸，它们被一次又一次地测量，
different hives, different times, different colonies, and it's always 3-8-7-inch. Langstruth called this area the bee space. 3-8-7-inch is the exact amount of space, bees need to move around a colony. They're like little hallways between the honeycombs. So then Langstroth took this idea of the bee space and he put it in a box. Inside each wooden hive box he would hang a series of
不同的蜂巢，不同的时间，不同的蜂群，而且总是3/8英寸。兰斯特劳斯将这个区域称为“蜂路”。3/8英寸是蜜蜂在蜂群中移动所需的精确空间。它们就像蜂窝之间的小走廊。于是兰斯特劳斯把“蜂路”这个想法放进了一个盒子里。在每个木制蜂箱里，他挂了一系列
removable frames, kind of like empty picture frames, and each one was spaced three eighths of an inch apart. When Langstroth put bees inside the box, they looked up at the frames and they thought, hey you know what? This looks a lot like home. Then up at the frames and they thought, hey, you know what? This looks a lot like home. Then other bees joined in and before you know it, they were making colonies inside these boxes. And the Langstruth hive was invented. It's the modern bee hive, the one that we still have today.
可移动的框，有点像空相框，每个框的间隔都是3/8英寸。当兰斯特劳斯把蜜蜂放进箱子里时，它们抬头看着这些框，心想，嘿，你知道吗？这看起来很像家。然后抬头看着这些框，心想，嘿，你知道吗？这看起来很像家。然后更多的蜜蜂加入进来，在你还没反应过来之前，它们已经在这些箱子里建立了蜂群。于是兰斯特劳斯蜂箱被发明了。这就是现代蜂箱，我们今天仍在使用的那个。
It was the first artificial hive which could be easily controlled and moved around. It changed everything about beekeeping. Oh, it was fundamental. I mean, there's just no doubt about that. Because once beekeepers can manage colonies, they can check on their health, say if it's a drought, they can help provide supplemental food.
这是第一个可以轻松控制和移动的人工蜂箱。它改变了关于养蜂的一切。哦，这是根本性的。我是说，毫无疑问。因为一旦养蜂人可以管理蜂群，他们就可以检查它们的健康状况，比方说如果发生旱灾，他们可以提供补充食物。
Langstress innovations meant people could keep more bees, and the bees could reuse their honeycombs because people weren't destroying them all the time, which allowed honey production to go way up. Langstruth published a book of his findings in 1853 called The Hive and the Honey Bee. It's still widely read in beekeeping circles today, and once it got out, beekeeping became big business all over the world. The hives start crammed with honey and ready for mantle rob.
兰斯特劳斯的创新意味着人们可以养更多的蜜蜂，而且蜜蜂可以重复使用它们的蜂巢，因为人们不是一直在毁坏它们，这使得蜂蜜产量大幅上升。兰斯特劳斯于1853年出版了一本名为《蜂箱与蜜蜂》的研究成果书。在今天的养蜂界，这本书仍然被广泛阅读，一旦消息传开，养蜂业在世界各地都成了大生意。蜂箱里塞满了蜂蜜，准备好让人类采收了。
The bees have made millions of journeys to add to that fresh store, to be or not to be, to be it is. After World War I, people kept innovating and honey production went from family farming to a giant commercial operation, by the end of World War II there were something like 5.9 million commercial beehives in the United States. It also set the stage for the next chapter of beekeeping, the rise of commercial pollination. In the 1950s small family farms started getting pushed out by big companies and industrial
蜜蜂已经进行了数百万次的飞行来增加新鲜的储藏，生存还是毁灭，这就是生存。第一次世界大战后，人们继续创新，蜂蜜产量从家庭农业转变为巨大的商业化运营，到第二次世界大战结束时，美国大约有590万个商业蜂箱。这也为养蜂业的下一个篇章——商业授粉的崛起——奠定了基础。20世纪50年代，小型家庭农场开始被大公司和工业化
agriculture. While family farms had fields with different crops growing side by side, the new model replaced the whole system with ever-expanding fields devoted to growing just one plant. Instead of planting cover crops to replenish the soil after the harvest, they just use fertilizer. Some of our commercial crops, like corn, rice, and wheat, are pollinated by the wind, but many of our fruits and vegetables rely on insects to do the job. As the entire business became more and more industrialized and shifted to monoculture, there was a need for greater certainty when it came to pollination.
农业所排挤。虽然家庭农场拥有种植不同作物的田地并排生长，但新的模式用专门种植单一作物的不断扩张的田地取代了整个系统。它们不种植覆盖作物在收获后来恢复土壤，而是只使用化肥。我们的一些商业作物，如玉米、水稻和小麦，是由风授粉的，但我们的许多水果和蔬菜依靠昆虫来完成这项工作。随着整个商业变得越来越工业化并转向单一栽培，在授粉方面需要更大的确定性。
Commercial bees, thanks to the Langstroth hive, were a perfect fit. Controlled by humans and highly portable, they were able to do more pollinating in a day than most wild insects do in a week. So instead of trusting the local ecosystem to pollinate their crops, many farms came to depend on this single domesticated species of bee. As farmers grew more crops, commercial beekeepers started earning more money by renting out their bees as pollinators. But while pollination is big business in the United States, actually, the US is pretty
多亏了兰斯特劳斯蜂箱，商业蜜蜂是一个完美的契合。由人类控制且高度便携，它们一天内完成的授粉工作比大多数野生昆虫一周内完成的还要多。因此，许多农场不再信任当地的生态系统来为作物授粉，而是开始依赖这种单一的驯化蜜蜂物种。随着农民种植更多的作物，商业养蜂人开始通过出租他们的蜜蜂作为授粉媒介来赚更多的钱。虽然授粉在美国是一桩大生意，但实际上，美国几乎是
much the only country that does this. commercial beekeeper from North Carolina. Every year he ships 1200 hives to California to pollinate almonds. In March, they'll come back to North Carolina where I will do high-bush blueberry pollination. After that, they will go up to Maine. That's where they'll do the low-bush blueberry pollination. And some will go to Wisconsin for cranberry pollination. And others will come right back to North Carolina for a cucumber
唯一一个这样做的国家。来自北卡罗来纳州的商业养蜂人。每年他运送1200个蜂箱到加州为杏树授粉。三月份，它们会回到北卡罗来纳州，我将在那里进行高丛蓝莓授粉。之后，它们将前往缅因州。那是它们进行低丛蓝莓授粉的地方。有些会去威斯康星州进行蔓越莓授粉。还有一些会直接回到北卡罗来纳州进行黄瓜
and watermelon pollination. Today commercial beekeepers get most of their income from pollination. They're paid around $200 per hive for a few weeks of pollinating almonds. So if you do the math, $200 per hive, times say $1000, that's $200,000, which sounds like pretty good money for three weeks of work, but least says the cost for keeping bees alive has shot through the roof in the last couple years. Right now beekeepers are facing one big challenge. You might already know about it if you watch the worst movie of 2008, the happening starring Mark Wahlberg as a beleaguered science teacher. I don't know if any of you guys have heard about this article in the New York Times?
和西瓜授粉。今天，商业养蜂人的大部分收入来自授粉。在给杏树授粉的几周里，每个蜂箱大约支付200美元。所以如果你算一下，每个蜂箱200美元，乘以比如1000个，那就是20万美元，对于三周的工作来说这听起来像是一笔相当不错的收入，但利斯说，在过去的几年里，让蜜蜂活着的成本已经急剧飙升。现在养蜂人面临着一个巨大的挑战。如果你看过2008年最烂的电影《灭顶之灾》（The Happening），由马克·沃尔伯格饰演一位身陷困境的理科老师，你可能已经知道了。我不知道你们当中是否有人听说过《纽约时报》上的这篇文章？
Well, apparently, honeybees are just disappearing all over the country. Tens and millions of them. All right, let's hear some theories about why this might be happening. Nobody? You know, an interesting one happened to the bees. In an interesting way, what happened to the bees? Tragically, I have seen the happening. Marky Mark is not good in this movie, but he's right. The bees are dying.
嗯，显然，全国各地的蜜蜂正在到处消失。成千上万，数以千万计。好了，让我们听听关于这可能发生的原因的一些理论。没有人？你知道的，蜜蜂身上发生了一件有趣的事。有趣的是，蜜蜂发生了什么？不幸的是，我看过《灭顶之灾》。马克·沃尔伯格在这部电影里演得不好，但他是对的。蜜蜂正在死去。
Adult bees leave the hive and never come back, leaving the babies to die. Researchers blame pesticides, disease, and parasites. Back in 2007, reports of mysterious bee plague called colony collapse disorder were making headlines all over the country, and it got people worried. There were articles warning us about the end of bees. There were studies by wreaked out scientists. Colony collapses when all the bees in a colony just disappear in the course of a few days. There's no bee corpses to do an autop on, and no obvious signs of poisoning.
成年蜜蜂离开蜂箱后就再也没有回来，留下幼蜂死去。研究人员将此归咎于杀虫剂、疾病和寄生虫。早在2007年，被称为蜂群崩溃紊乱症（Colour Collapse Disorder）的神秘蜂瘟的报道就登上了全国各地的头条新闻，这让人们感到担忧。有文章警告我们蜜蜂的末日。有一些精神失常的科学家进行的研究。蜂群崩溃是指蜂群中的所有蜜蜂在短短几天内就消失了。没有蜜蜂的尸体来进行尸检，也没有明显的中毒迹象。
Around 2007, it was happening a lot. The number of cases technically labeled as colony collapse has actually gone down since then, but Jeff Lee says it's still happening. B's disappearing are dying in huge numbers. This last year, I had the most losses I have ever had. And I'm reading the literature and I'm trying to do everything I can to keep the B's healthy. A recent survey of commercial beekeepers found the average yearly dial freight is about 40%, which is way higher than the 10 to 15% which used to be normal.
2007年前后，这种情况经常发生。自那以后，技术上被贴上蜂群崩溃标签的案例数量实际上已经下降，但杰夫·李表示这种情况仍在发生。消失或死亡的蜜蜂数量巨大。去年，我遇到了我有生以来最大的损失。我正在阅读相关文献，并尽我所能保持蜜蜂的健康。最近对商业养蜂人的一项调查发现，平均每年的死亡率约为40%，这远高于过去正常的10%到15%。
Researchers point to increase use of pesticides as one factor, and when the bees started dying, there were protests. No more poison! You're not just killing the bees, you're killing yourself! But pesticides aren't the only culprit. Another problem is an invasive parasitic mite from Asia called Varoa Destructor. Once it has penetrated the bee hive, the varoa mite multiplies in the brood cells where the queen has laid her eggs. They use their mouth parts to suck a blood-like fluid from the bee larvae and then lay their eggs in the brood cell. This is a video from 2017. It's made by Bayer, the largest producer of pesticides in the
研究人员指出，杀虫剂使用量的增加是一个因素，当蜜蜂开始死亡时，人们举行了抗议活动。不要再有毒药了！你们不只是在杀死蜜蜂，你们是在杀死自己！但杀虫剂并不是唯一的罪魁祸首。另一个问题是来自亚洲的入侵寄生螨，被称为狄斯螨（Varroa Destructor）。一旦进入蜂箱，狄斯螨就会在蜂王产卵的育雏房中大量繁殖。它们用口器吸食蜂幼虫的血液样液体，然后将卵产在育雏房中。这是一段2017年的视频。它由拜耳制作，拜耳是世界上最大的杀虫剂生产商
world. And given that, of course, Bayer wants us to focus on the mites. By the time the bee hatches, it is weakened, often infected with viruses, and has a shortened lifespan. The varoamite can also be carried by the bee into other bee hives. Varoamites have wiped out tens of millions of bee hives in the United States. Since the European honeybee didn't evolve alongside the mite, the bees don't have a natural defense. And because most of the commercial beehives in the country end up in a single place in California every February, we've created the ideal scenario for vero mites to spread
世界。鉴于此，拜耳当然希望我们将注意力集中在螨虫上。当蜜蜂孵化时，它已经变得虚弱，经常感染病毒，并且寿命缩短。狄斯螨还可以被蜜蜂带入其他蜂箱。狄斯螨已经消灭了美国数以千万计的蜂箱。由于欧洲蜜蜂并没有与螨虫一起进化，因此蜜蜂没有天然的防御能力。而且因为全国大部分的商业蜂箱每年二月份都会最终汇集到加州的同一个地方，我们为狄斯螨从一个蜂箱传播到另一个蜂箱创造了理想的情景
from one hive to another. Which is a real threat to our food supply. Because our whole agricultural system has become dependent on this single, vulnerable species of insect. And now it's hard to imagine feeding the country without them. It's inextricable from industrial ag, which the United States excels in. Not just excels, it defines industrial ag. That's at the root of all of our ability to have monocultural orchards, you know, your pumpkins and your raspberries and blueberries and blackberries, you know, you don't get those massive tracks of production without pollination. But there are farmers today who are trying to rely less on honeybee livestock by reintroducing
这对我们的食物供应构成了真正的威胁。因为我们的整个农业系统已经变得依赖于这种单一、脆弱的昆虫物种。现在很难想象没有它们如何养活这个国家。它与工业化农业密不可分，美国在这方面表现卓越。不仅仅是卓越，它定义了工业化农业。这是我们能够拥有单一栽培果园的所有能力的根源，你知道的，你的南瓜、覆盆子、蓝莓和黑莓，如果没有授粉，你就无法获得那些大规模的生产。但今天有一些农户正试图通过将野蜂和昆虫重新引入授粉景观来减少对家养蜜蜂的依赖。
wild bees and insects into the pollination landscape. According to entomologists, just a small amount of plant diversity can help boost the population of wild bees and other pollinators like butterflies and beetles. An example of this is something called a pollinator hedge row. Basically, a small strip of native weeds or flowers near the edge of a field that can provide habitat and food for wild insects and bees all year round. The history of agriculture has been a history of control, trying to bend nature to our will and make it predictable and productive.
根据昆虫学家的说法，只要少量的植物多样性就可以帮助提高野蜂和其他传粉媒介（如蝴蝶和甲虫）的数量。这方面的一个例子被称为“传粉植物篱笆”。基本上，田地边缘的一小条原生杂草或花朵，可以全年为野生昆虫和蜜蜂提供栖息地和食物。农业的历史一直是一部控制的历史，试图让自然屈服于我们的意志，使其变得可预测和高产。
But for the sake of the bees and maybe even for the future of our food supply, we might need an agricultural system that's just a little bit more wild. More at the bottom about how domesticated bees became a symbol of conservation. After this. So in the story you mentioned that save the bees has become a big part of the conservation movement in the last couple of years. When I was a kid, it was all wails and pandas, another charismatic megafauna. How did bees take off is both a focus of activism and as a symbol?
但为了蜜蜂的利益，也许甚至为了我们食物供应的未来，我们需要一个稍微狂野一点的农业系统。接下来将有更多关于驯化蜜蜂如何成为保护象征的底层内容。听完这个再说。所以在故事中你提到“拯救蜜蜂”在过去几年里已经成为保护运动的重要组成部分。当我还是个孩子的时候，全都是鲸鱼和大熊猫，其他有魅力的巨型动物。蜜蜂是如何既成为激进主义的焦点又成为一个象征而腾飞的？
Well, I think it really started around 2006 with the onset of the colony collapse disorder scare. six with the onset of the colony collapse disorder scare, honey bees really became this symbol of confluence of all these environmental problems. They had the advantage of being cute and cuddly and easily identifiable creatures. Environmentalists really latched on to them, and in some cases some states actually sued to create protections for honey bees. You probably heard the protests. There was actually a really huge protest in the UK a few years back where protesters dressed up
嗯，我认为它确实始于2006年前后，随着蜂群崩溃紊乱症恐慌的爆发。随着蜂群崩溃紊乱症恐慌的爆发，蜜蜂真正成为了所有这些环境问题交汇的象征。它们具有可爱、呆萌且易于识别的生物的优势。环保主义者真正抓住了它们，在某些情况下，一些州甚至起诉以建立对蜜蜂的保护。你可能听过抗议活动。几年前英国其实有一场非常大型的抗议活动，抗议者打扮成
like Winnie the Pooh were holding signs and you know singing songs and basically we are all beekeepers. Winnie the Pooh wasn't the greatest beekeeper. No way. In fact, yeah, you know, most of those hives that Winnie the Pooh was actually robbing were paper wasps, which don't actually produce honey. But so when you talk to most people about saving the bees, the image that they probably have in their head is like of an orange and black honey bee. And this is the result of all of this promotion and cartoon bees, like the honey net Cheerios B. One person I spoke with for this series, Catherine Baldock, as she's a biologist in the UK, and she says the big reason people care about bees and conservation is the honey bee. They're kind of like the panda,
小熊维尼的模样，手里举着标语，你知道的，唱着歌，基本上我们都是养蜂人。小熊维尼并不是最好的养蜂人。绝对不是。事实上，是的，你知道，小熊维尼实际上在抢劫的大多数蜂箱都是黄蜂，它们实际上并不产蜜。所以当你和大多数人谈论拯救蜜蜂时，他们脑海中浮现的形象可能就像是一只橙色和黑色的蜜蜂。这是所有这些宣传和卡通蜜蜂的结果，比如蜜蜂麦圈（Honey Nut Cheerios）的蜜蜂。我在这个系列中采访过的一个人，凯瑟琳·鲍尔多克，她是英国的一位生物学家，她说人们关心蜜蜂和保护的主要原因是蜜蜂。它们有点像大熊猫，
aren't they, of um, in verse-brick conservation. I think it is a good thing by conserving or by trying to help bees with generally improving habitats, putting more flowers in, and that's going to benefit a whole host of other species. So yeah, I think it is a good thing. They're kind of like a bit of a symbol of conservation in a way, aren't they? The panda of bees are struggling. In fact, we're losing about 40% per year, but they aren't an extinction risk. They're managed just like cows or sheep,
不是吗，在无脊椎动物保护中。我认为这是一件好事，通过保护或通过试图通过普遍改善栖息地、种植更多花卉来帮助蜜蜂，这将使一大批其他物种受益。所以是的，我觉得这是一件好事。它们在某种程度上有点像保护的象征，不是吗？蜜蜂正在苦苦挣扎。事实上，我们每年大约失去40%的蜜蜂，但它们并不面临灭绝的风险。它们就像奶牛或绵羊一样被管理，
so they'll probably be okay. It's really the native bees that we're worried about. And the key distinction here is that things that benefit honey bees don't always benefit native bees, especially when the two species are competing for the same resources, you know. So actually, this has kind of become a problem in recent years. Beekeepers have lobbied the federal government to be allowed to put their honeybee hives
所以它们可能会没事的。我们真正担心的是本地蜜蜂。这里的一个关键区别是，对蜜蜂有益的事情并不总是对本地蜜蜂有益，特别是当这两个物种在争夺相同的资源时，你知道的。所以实际上，这在近年来已经成为一个问题。养蜂人游说联邦政府允许他们将他们的蜂箱放入国家公园，在那里蜜蜂可以与本地蜜蜂争夺花卉资源。所以这是一个被管理的物种——蜜蜂，与本地物种竞争的情况。
into national parks, where the bees then can out-compete native bees for the floral resources. So that's a case where you have this managed species, a honey bee, out competing with a native species. Wow. So honey bees might not be a great symbol for conservation after all. So what species would be more accurate if you wanted to have an invertebrate mascot for environmentalists? Well, there's no shortage of candidates. That's for sure, you know, about 20,000 beast species in the world. But, you know, let's run through just a couple that's spring to the top of your mind. The black sweat bee, you know, this is kind of like the aziaz born of bees, you know, all
哇。所以蜜蜂毕竟可能不是保护的绝佳象征。那么，如果你想为环保主义者选一个无脊椎动物吉祥物，什么物种会更准确呢？嗯，候选者绝对不缺。这是肯定的，你知道的，世界上大约有20000种蜜蜂。但是，你知道，让我们快速浏览几个浮现在你脑海顶端的。黑汗蜂，你知道的，这有点像是蜜蜂中的阿兹特克人，你知道的，全是黑色的，看起来更像是一只长着这种紫色眼睛的苍蝇。你知道的，你有地面筑巢的蜜蜂，比如壁蜂，它们，你知道的，有点像蜜蜂，更毛糙一点，边缘更粗糙一点。然后是锈斑熊蜂，它最近被加入了濒危物种名单。它其实非常可爱和呆萌。你知道的，它看起来像一只熊蜂，除了它的背上有两个小铁锈色的橙色斑块。
black, kind of looks more like a fly with these kind of purple eyes. You know, you've got ground nesting bees, like the mason bees, which are, you know, kind of resemble honey bees, a little more shaggy, a little more rough around the edges. And then the rusty patched bumblebee, which was actually recently added to the endangered species lists. It's actually quite cute and cuddly. You know, it looks like a bumblebee, except it's got these two little rust-colored orange patches on its back.
那将是一只仅凭可爱就能竞争的蜜蜂。除了为蜜蜂寻找完美的毛茸茸保护象征之外，如果人们关心蜜蜂和蜜蜂种群的健康，他们能做些什么呢？嗯，你知道，这就是有一点好消息的地方，因为与其他那些可能有些抽象或在个人行动方面难以理解的巨大的、迫在眉睫的环境问题不同，比如气候变化，
That would be a bee that could compete, you know, on cuteness alone. Other than finding the perfect fuzzy symbol for conservation when it comes to bees, if people are concerned about bees and the health of bee populations, what can they do? Well, you know, this is where there's a bit of good news because unlike other big, looming environmental issues, which can kind of be abstract or maybe difficult to wrap your head around in terms of individual action, you know, things like climate change, for instance,
对于传粉媒介，你实际上可以做一些事情，为蜜蜂创造直接的利益。不幸的是，这不包括购买农贸市场的本地蜂蜜之类的事情。别误会我，我喜欢蜂蜜，但如果我们购买由蜜蜂创造的产品，对本地蜜蜂其实没有任何帮助。后院养蜂也是如此。通过饲养这种农业家畜，对帮助传粉媒介没有任何作用。为此，你可以做一些事情，显然就是在你的院子里种植更多的本地花卉和植物。
with pollinators, you can actually do something that will create direct benefit for bees. This doesn't include, you know, unfortunately, buying things like a local honey from the farmer's market. And don't get me wrong, I love honey, but it doesn't actually help native bees if we're purchasing a product that's created by honey bees. The same thing goes with backyard beekeeping. It doesn't do anything to help pollinators by raising basically this agricultural livestock. So toward that, and there are things you can do, which is obviously plant more native flowers and plants in your yard.
能够在一整年中不同时间开花的植物，为这些蜜蜂提供觅食的东西。其他事情，显然是避免使用杀虫剂，例如，或者考虑让你的草坪变得稍微狂野一点，让所有那些蒲公英在春天长出来。这些事情确实可以很大程度上帮助本地传粉媒介。我对此感到非常兴奋，因为我讨厌打理草坪，而让它野蛮生长完全符合我作为环保主义者和作为一个懒惰人类的道德。这对我来说似乎太完美了。
Plants that can bloom at different times throughout the year to give those bees something to feed on. Other things, obviously, avoiding pesticides, for example, or perhaps consider letting your lawn go a bit wild, letting all those dandelions come up in the springtime. Those are things that can really help native pollinators quite a bit. I'm so excited about this because I hate taking care of the lawn and letting it go wild is exactly in keeping with both my ethic as a conservationist and as a lazy human. That seems perfect for me.
这就对了。现在你有了借口。因为邻居会生气，我可以说我是为了蜜蜂才这么做的。没错。非常感谢。谢谢你，罗曼。如果你想了解更多关于蜜蜂与我们环境景观之间联系的内容，你应该去听听亚当的节目。它叫《蜜蜂的生意》。
There you go. Now you've got an explanation. Because the neighbors get mad and I can just say I'm doing it for the bees. Exactly. Thank you so much. Thank you, Roman. If you'd like to hear more about the connections between honey bees and our environmental landscape, you should check out Adam's show. It's called The Business of Bees.
它在各大播客平台都可以收听。“99%隐形”本周由亚当·埃灵顿制作，克里斯·巴鲁贝剪辑，谢里夫·优素福混音与技术制作，肖恩·里尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员还有埃姆内特·菲茨杰拉德、艾弗里·特罗勒姆、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、
It's available everywhere. You get your podcasts. 99% of visible was produced this week by Adam Allington, edited by Chris Baroube, mixed in tech production by Sheref Yusif, music by Sean Real. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Trollham, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee,
德兰妮·霍尔、索菲娅·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的“无线电街”。“99%隐形”是来自PRX的Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在 radiotopia.fm 上可以找到这个节目，你可以在 Facebook 上找到并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，以及@节目 99PI，或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。
Delaney Hall, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland California 99% invisible is a member of radio topia from PRX a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting fun mall at radio topia.fm you can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or on Instagram and read it too.
不过，随时欢迎你来我们的蜂巢 999PI.org 做客。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。
But you're always welcome to hang out at our hive at 999PI.org Radio Tepia from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欢迎随时来我们在 999PI.org Radio Tepia（由 PRX 提供）的蜂巢串门。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。